am 19 april verkünden die grünen das
annalena baerbock kanzlerkandidaten wird
der kanzlerkandidatin wird
entschuldigung und diese termin ansage
der grünen setzt zwei andere kandidaten
jetzt brutal unter druck denn auch bei
der union kann es nur einen geben
laschet würste sieger jetzt wird es
schmutzig der fight des jahres laschet
gegen söder aachener hobbit power gegen
fränkische urgewalt sowie stets da
gerade
inzwischen haben sich mehrere cdu
bundestagsabgeordnete für den csu mann
söder ausgesprochen öffentlich also
jetzt nicht weil die den mögen es geht
ja gar nicht sondern weil sie schied
haben mit dem kandidaten laschet ihr
bundestagsmandat zu verlieren spätestens
bis pfingsten soll die k frage geklärt
werden nach welchen kriterien
wir werden nach dem kriterium
entscheiden wer die größten aussichten
hat in ganz deutschland die wahl zu
gewinnen
gut so da wird hätten wir das auch
geklärt das war die heute show spaß nein
so einfach ist es auch nicht denn wer
brücken armin gerade genau zugehört hat
er sprach von chancen in ganz
deutschland mit betonung auf gangs ein
subtiler hinweis darauf dass hier noch
nie einen bayer deutscher geworden ist
der kanzler wäre gut wenn man jetzt
streng auf aktuelle umfragen guckt dann
glauben nur 29 prozent der
unionsanhänger an laschet weil so der 79
prozent in der gesamtbevölkerung sind
sogar nur 19 prozent laschet fans 19
prozent oder wie olaf scholz sagen würde
nach den sternen greifen
laschet hat im moment wirklich ein anti
lauf muss man so sagen
bei markus lanz zum beispiel behauptet
er dass deutsche digitalisierungs
debakel hätte nichts zu tun mit 16
jahren cdu regierung um dann irgendwann
zu sagen ja
irgendwie doch am ende der sendung hatte
der mann sich quasi aufgegeben
plötzlich ist man der anti märz und ist
nicht so und ausgerechnet der der so
brutal und massiv wie kein anderer genau
wie auch gegen diese flüchtlingspolitik
vom leder gezogen hat nämlich markus
söder
er ist jetzt plötzlich der mann an ihrer
seite ja dann ist es ja dann ist es so
darf ich jetzt bitte nach hause herr
lanz eine sendung wirklich wie ein
verkehrsunfall
man konnte nicht weggucken herr laschet
sie haben eine menge vor
und bald kanzlerkandidat nein also die
nein ich würde ich glaube ich bin noch
nicht bereit in der regierung nicht
darüber in der ein nein nein nein auch
nicht nein das will sie im sumpf
das hat doch damit nächste doch nein
nein nein nein nein nein nein und er
sein leben ist das stimmt ja auch gar
nicht doch passieren darf ich noch mal
sagen ja nein wirklich nur minimal von
uns bearbeitet sein rivale söder hier
macht derweil einen auf muttis bester
und fordert das aber unbedingt angela
merkel mit entscheiden muss wer kandidat
wird
warum eigentlich schleimer soda
verkörpert einigermaßen gut den macher
also zumindest wenn man sich die
bayerische corona bilanz nicht zu genau
anguckt einen kleinen unverbindlichen
tipp hätte ich allerdings an den man
wenn man angeblich kanzler aller
deutschen werden möchte bisschen weniger
große fresse wie geil bayern ist es ist
ein stück weit auch die bestätigung der
bayerischen linie
wir haben übrigens als erster die ffw
zwei masken pflicht eingeführt überall
bei uns klappt so als einziges
bundesland habe vor weihnachten bereich
zunächst ohne taskforce gemacht wir
hatten übrigens als erstes bundesland
auch masken pflicht sogar an der
grundschule eingeführt wir haben bislang
jedenfalls zum glück keinen impfstoff in
bayern machen müssen wie einige andere
bundesländer das getan was soll ja mal
nicht überhöhen und sagen wir sind die
besten aber ja vielleicht doch
neuerdings bestellte schon russischen
impfstoff nur für bayern so weit sind
wir schon
und wer ist überhaupt der echte söder
der asyl tourismus oder von 2018 oder
der bäume um aber von heute authentisch
sind wahrscheinlich nur der
machtanspruch und sein talent zum dissen
ja und das hat er einer seiner minister
sagt im spiegel anonym
wer für söder arbeitet müssen sich in
ein system der angst einfügen
wobei muss man sagen er das schon sehr
geschickt macht mit dem wissen auch die
mobbing-attacken gegen den armen laschet
muss man ja regelrecht übersetzen
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob jeder
wirklich den ernst der lage verstanden
hat ich kann auch an allen sagen den ich
auch schönste für in wünsche und ihren
ostern runterkommen und ausruhen und was
anders denken wollen wir denken
weiterhin corona wir passen auf
ich finde es auch sehr seltsam
mit der cdu vorsitzende mit der
cdu-kanzlerin ein halbes jahr vor der
wahl streitet der mobbing könig seit
tagen geht das so in einer tour
giftpfeile auf laschet
da war söder noch nicht mal gesagt dass
er wirklich antritt wenn es am ende gar
nicht macht wofür hat er dann die marke
laschet komplett zerstört weil es kann
böse ist ja das hat ja auch tradition
und wenn man darüber nachdenkt es ist
echt wahnsinn wenn der sänger schon
alles für seine karriere aus dem weg
geräumt hat der weiß blaue ring wir
helfen den politischen opfern von markus
söder war ministerpräsident sogar alles
genommen heute noch mich als spieler
musst mich nicht vor fremden der weiß
blaue ringe schauen wir nicht weg
ja politik ein schmutziges geschäft idee
wie wäre es denn mit weder söder noch
laschet das ging jedoch aus der unions
fraktion kommt jetzt dieser frische
vorschlag warum nicht rolf brinkmann
ralph brinkhaus ja warum nicht der hat
sich das amt des
cdu-fraktionsvorsitzenden gegen den
erklärten willen der kanzlerin
geschnappt und kritisiert in corona
debatten die eigene regierung respekt
wir brauchen in diesem land nicht nur
eine reform sondern wahrscheinlich sogar
eine kleine revolution
sie haben ganz richtig gehört ein cdu
mann ruft zur revolution auf karl marx
bei öffnet sich in seiner ohne und ich
weiter das übrigens völlig ernst ralph
brinkhaus hat die offizielle
unterstützung der heute show er vereint
das beste aus ost und west
denn er ist ostwestfale und unser
kommender bundeskanzler der einzige der
deutschland jetzt noch retten kann ist
ein gott verdammter steuerberater aus
rheda wiedenbrück
[Musik]
nichts was nicht lassen ja das reicht
völlig aus
[Musik]
ich freue mich darauf mit ihnen ins
gespräch zu kommen guter mann
am ende sind die so doof und nehmen
trotzdem söder viele machen sich sorgen
was aus der union wird wenn die im
herbst sprechen wir das unvorstellbare
aus in der opposition landet ich habe im
grundgesetz nachgeguckt das ist
theoretisch erlaubt manche experten
befürchten sogar cdu und csu könnten
sich in dem fall radikalisieren claus
von wagner zum beispiel
er leitet beim verfassungsschutz die neu
gegründete abteilung für ansicht
bürgerliche parteien kurz vorm
durchdrehen er von wagner wo vor genau
haben sie da angst
das liegt wohl auch daran weil ich die
union ist inhaltlich total entkernt
der letzte daseinszweck ist regieren
wenn du ihnen das auch noch nimmst kann
im grunde alles passieren wir haben ja
mal eine wasserdichte beweiskette
zusammengetragen die genaue erklärt
wohin die reise da geht ja jetzt
verstehen sie wohl was ich meine
was uns da droht noch nicht herr von
wagner sind sie blind ist doch immer so
wenn ein mächtiger boss geht dann gibt
es machtkämpfe und am ende setzte sich
die radikalen durch das haben mir die
kollegen von der abteilung klaren
kriminalität auch besteht nicht und es
geht ja schon los die unionsfraktion hat
jetzt das wehrhafte demokratie gesetz
ausgebremst
das sollte dafür sorgen dass
organisationen die präventionsarbeit
gegen rechts wagen nicht mehr alle vier
jahre um unterstützung betteln müssen
denn es ist ja nun mal so dass dass der
rechtsextremismus die größte bedrohung
in unserem lande ist umso eher blöder
dass dieses gesetz erst mal wohl doch
nicht kommt dank der union
seehofer ist von seinem eigenen laden
zitat maßlos enttäuschten überlegt schon
die partei zu wechseln
ach wer soll denn aufnehmen die grünen
zum beispiel überlegen sie mal ein horst
seehofer ist inzwischen zu links für die
union
meine kollegen und nicht tragen da immer
mehr indizien zusammen hier schauen sie
mal blauen in sachsen da die cdu gerade
im bündnis für demokratie und toleranz
den zuschuss gestrichen weil ihnen das
zu links war und zwar die cdu zusammen
mit der afg und zusammen mit der
ultrarechten splitterpartei dritter weg
im grunde so eine art trachtengruppe die
30er jahre nach spielt aber die sind
natürlich auch für solchen brauchen wir
hier verhandeln
ja das sind grauenhafte bilder aber nur
wegen plauen kann man ja nicht sagen die
cdu driftet vielleicht bald nach rechts
denken sie schon ans georg maßen ex-chef
meiner behörde fans nennen ihn immer
noch den rechten harry potter urheber
wunderbarer zitate wie ich bin vor 30
jahren nicht in die cdu angetreten damit
1,8 millionen araber nach deutschland
kommen so und der kandidiert wohl bald
in thüringen für ein cdu
bundestagsmandat bernd löcke gefällt das
klar kann es sein dass eine cdu in der
opposition deutlich konservativer wird
aber das heißt ja nie hätte ich habe
nicht behauptet dass es so kommen muss
beim kommenden unions machtkampf kann
sich der rechte flügel durchsetzen aber
es gibt natürlich noch einen anderen
flügel den gruppen stichwort masken
affäre da kommt jeden tag was neues raus
hier
alfred sauter ehemaliger bayerischer
justizminister hat nach sz recherchen
wohl auch noch an dem schnelltests
verdient 300.000 euro provision vom
hersteller eines sauter mail an markus
söder das büro den stunden und können
sich jetzt mal selber ausrechnen
gut dafür im nachhinein klingen jetzt
viele syrer sätze über den kollegen sei
da er irgendwie ein bisschen lustiger
alfred sauter ein erfahrener
langjähriger abgeordneter ein taktiker
ein meister des arrangieren es auch von
möglichkeiten für seinen landkreis
ein meister des arrangieren von mehr
geld für sein konto verstehe aber wenn
ich ihre theorie aus spaß mal folge
davon war
was müsste man den konkret machen um die
radikalisierung der union noch zu
verhindern
da gibt es nur eine lösung die dürfen
nicht aus der regierung fliegen
wir müssen die alle so wichtig ist mir
auch wieder nicht claus von wagner
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
mime hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und sie
töten - wollt dann abonniert jetzt den
kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]